hey guys it's Justine and today we have
one of the brand new iPad minis that
were just announced I've had a few of
these over the years and it was always
one of my favorite devices because of
its size I've been traveling a lot for
the past ten years so having something
that is portable and easy to take with
me I mean now I mostly use my phone but
for people who don't have phones or for
scenarios like smart homes or people
that are in restaurants that are now
switching to iPads there are so many
other scenarios for this thing than just
a media device obviously it is an
incredible media device but the iPad
Mini has a bunch of updates from the
previous version I honestly thought that
Apple from thought about the iPad Mini
until recently it has made its revival
and it is here and we're gonna check it
out this is the 256 gig Wi-Fi and
cellular version obviously they have it
in both models if you do just want a
Wi-Fi version is the silver version it
also comes in a Space Gray and the Rose
Bowl it's still exciting every time even
if I know what is inside the box so the
first thing that you're gonna notice is
yes it does have that same look as the
old models it is so shocking to me is if
Apple released this as a phone next year
I would not even I would be like alright
well I wouldn't even think twice like
this is a realistic size that I feel
like we would be ok with if this was a
phone I wouldn't even be surprised I'm
like Hello I will take your call just
seen here I think most people would be
more shocked that I answered my phone
I hardly ever talk on the phone most of
the time I am texting or you find me on
Twitter okay we've got our iPad one
thing that I think that you guys are
gonna notice and it's a lot of people
talking about online is this is the same
design as the old version so the
original iPad like not much has changed
as far as looks it still has our touch
ID let's see what else is in the box
we've got all of our paperwork as usual
oh look at this
this is something I haven't seen in so
long a SIM card ejector am I being
sarcastic
that's for you to determine Oh little
teeny-tiny Apple stickers and that seems
to be all of our reading material
something that should with every iPhone
maybe in the future well watch charging
brick lightning cable and that my
friends is everything that is in the box
oh my phone just said do you want to set
up your new iPad yes I do iPhone thank
you you know me so well so the iPad Mini
has a 7.9 inch screen and what's great
about the new version of the iPad Mini
is it also has the true tone display I'm
actually a huge fan of true tone display
on my iPad is it do a lot of reading and
emails on my iPad so it Just's to
whatever lighting conditions you're
currently in that's best for your eyes
so that is something that I do leave on
I do tend to turn it off when I'm on my
laptop
mostly because if I'm doing any sort of
color correction in my videos or my
photos I just like knowing that my
screen hasn't changed colors but if I'm
just reading or doing anything like that
I'm a huge fan hey we're in continue
setting this up it's official
let's click yes Whitney knew a 12 Bionic
chip you're getting a performance boost
so the performance is boosted by three
times and the graphics by nine I would
like to see a show of hands of anyone
who had watched my pop Ross painting
tutorial on the iPad pro if you did and
you would like to see me try to do a Bob
Ross tutorial on this iPad Mini let me
know because this is really exciting
news the iPad Mini now finally has Apple
pencil support yeah well it doesn't have
Apple pencil to support it does support
Apple pencil one and one of the main
reasons for that the iPad pro has the
magnetic flat edged Apple pencil so that
magnetically charges magnetically pairs
just like this that's it it's magic so
if this is one of the older designs
obviously that pencil would not work
with this which leaves us with the old
style of charging you basically take off
the cap of the Apple pencil and you just
stick it in the bottom it's super silly
but I mean I feel like at this point
we've been doing it for so long that it
doesn't even seem strange anymore
or does it having applicants of support
on these smaller versions is seriously
really incredible
I just love the use cases of the iPad
that are not your traditional media
viewing devices mostly what I use it for
it's used in healthcare it's used in
restaurants it's used in smart homes
there are so many other things outside
of just those use cases that most of us
normally use it for I'm excited that it
does have an open support the iPad air
also has Apple pencil support and it has
support for Bluetooth keyboards did I
say support way too many times perhaps I
did I also have one of the iPad Mini
Smart Covers what color is this papaya
have you guys seen the new Apple watch
colors for spring I have they're
beautiful it's so little like I just
think over how great it is like it's
small but in comparison to the iPhone
oh this bone is huge I can't figure out
if this phone as huge or the iPad is
small Wow Wow
like I haven't held one of these in so
long and the screen actually looks
really good it is just such a perfect
little tiny device look at you let's
open up this pencil can you believe I
haven't even used a knife this entire
video and I don't want to get up yes I
won't use one Oh am i there you go
charge up my friend
yep pair it up look at me taking notes
look at my notes only draw with Apple
pencil your fingers will be used for
scrolling instead you can change this
heading okay I had written in cursive in
solo oh do I mean it yes okay well maybe
writing is not something that I'm good
at this is the Apple pencil one in
comparison to your the Apple pencil -
it's a little bit taller obviously
because it's got this little cap here
and just kind of the flat edge the
magnetic to stick to the top let me show
you this thing in comparison to the iPad
pro it's just craziness size difference
between look at this this is a house and
it's also upside down hmm I can't do
that with homekit because I'm not sure
what you mean by upside Shh oh gosh look
I went on my first today at Apple
sessions if you guys have never gone to
him before it was so much fun like I
brought a bunch of friends we all went
and we drew pictures like we did a
procreate tutorial this is definitely
not my best work I'm not entirely proud
of it so we're just gonna make it really
is crazy just to see these side by side
because the iPad pro because the iPad
pro is really beautiful like it is a
beautiful device well the video looks
pretty good I'm a little biased because
it's my own video like I love the iPad
I love the iPad so much like just
something about just holding these
devices it makes me happy like they just
have such an incredible feel like
everything is so intuitive and it's so
cool to watch kids use these devices and
I think that's also something that this
is really primitive for
I've seen so many incredible use cases
for this also in the classroom I mean if
you're looking for something small
portable and compact look why not
perfect size it now has Apple pencil
support you can connect a bluetooth
keyboard to it if you choose to do so
now when I'm traveling I bring my iPad
and my macbook this thing is so huge
especially when I have the keyboard
attached to it
I mean I'm essentially traveling with
two laptops at this point just this with
this little cover I can put this in my
yoga pants pocket easily well I just
wanted to show you guys a quick little
look at the iPad Mini I'm so excited I
really want to do another Bob Ross
tutorial with it so if you haven't seen
that video a little link in the
description if you want to watch me draw
a Bob Ross tutorial on my iPad pro I
didn't give you really fun to do one on
here if you want to leave me a
suggestion for which Bob Ross tutorial
you would like to see me do leave those
in the comments below and in the
meantime I'm going to finish setting up
this iPad yet some of my apps ready I
also want to test out some of the
augmented reality apps so if you have
any other suggestions for ones that I
should check out also think those in the
comments below and I will see you guys
very very soon look at it it's just so
great
[Music]